the results of a new study suggest the
number of adults living with dementia
around the world will nearly triple to
more than 150 million by 2050.
obesity and smoking are among the risk
factors likely to drive this increase
u.s researchers estimate that north
africa and the middle east in particular
will see a dramatic rise
more people
getting older
and indulging in unhealthy habits
that's what a landmark study found were
the main reasons for an expected spike
in dementia
cases will rise in every country but the
middle east and north africa will see an
almost 400 percent rise in the number of
people with the degenerative brain
disease by the year 2050.
the projections in the in north africa
and the middle east were were quite
large and this was due to
large increases both in population
growth and population aging and so these
two demographic factors
in particular in that region drove these
large anticipated increases in dementia
burden
dementia leads to a loss of brain
function thinking reasoning and
remembering destroying lives slowly
researchers say that though the numbers
are not set in stone they should serve
as a warning to act now
this is an important
important disease to consider in terms
of future planning no matter where you
are
europe will see a less pronounced
increase with 14 million cases in 2050
compared to around 8 million now
believed to be a result of the older
population
and along a history of grappling with
unhealthy lifestyles
healthy diets lower alcohol intake stop
smoking
so there's this sort of mantra look
after the heart and you'll look after
the head
experts say healthy eating campaigns as
well as the use of medication like
aspirin to prevent stroke have helped to
combat the disease
we're now starting to see a decrease in
the numbers of some dementias such as
vascular dementias so
the the sort of health promotion
elements of managing risk factors is
starting to have an impact
some encouraging signs for policy makers
faced with a surge in demand for
dementia care in the decades to come